[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Bruno rotaillot bonjour monsieur
reotillot merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté
notre invitation sénateur de la vandé
président du groupe les républicains au
Sénat et vous êtes membres de cette
fameuse commission mixte parutire sur le
projet de immigration dont on va parler
on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse régionale représentée par
Stéphane Vernet de wouest France bonjour
Stéphane bonjour Oriane bonjour Bruno
retilloonour Vernet bonjour à Ouest
France Bonjour à l'ouest en général qui
m cher Bruno retaillot la nuit la soirée
et la nuit ont été agité il y a eu des
longes suspensions de Séan on va en
parler vous reprenez vos travaux ce
matin à 10h30 est-ce qu'un accord est
encore
possible tout est possible à vrai dire
tout est possible ce qui a cusé ce
trouble
hier ce n'est pas un caprice de tel ou
tel c'est tout simplement qu'en arrivant
à la commission mixte paritaire à 17h
j'ai vu que le gouvernement ne tenait
pas ses engagements après trois réunions
à Matignon qui ont duré longtemps qui
ont duré plusieurs heures et après toute
une journée où j'ai
tenté par des échanges notamment de
rédaction de version sur la question des
prestations sociales qui est clé pour
moi elle est clé pour moi parce que les
Français en ont marre de payer toujours
plus pour avoir toujours moins de
servicees on pourra parler de la me tout
à l'heure quand j'entendais
l'information que les complémentaires
vont augmenter de plus de 8 % en 2024
vous croyez que les Français qui sont de
moins en moins bien soignés qui payent
de plus en plus ils vont supporter
longtemps que certains avec des filières
vivent au crochets du système donc pour
moi c'est quelque chose de capital on
vous sent en colère on avait on avait
réglé un certain nombre de problèmes et
le gouvernement fait mine de découvrir à
17h alors que allait commencer la
commission son mix paritaire que
finalement il y avait un malentendu non
il y a pas eu de malentendu le texte du
Sénat il est clair il y a qu'un texte
démocratiquement on est encore une
démocratie en France il y a un parlement
le la seule assemblée de ce Parlement
qui a été en mesure de voter un texte
c'est le Sénat il y a donc qu'un texte
le texte du Sénat c'est simple il dit
que pour les pressations il y a bien sûr
les allocations familiales il y a la pas
il y avait un certain nombre de points y
compris les APL ce cette question-là je
l'ai évoqué devant madame born monsieur
Yester monsieur Darmanin la veille
dimanche soir on s'est réuni à 19h et
les choses étaient claires à ce
moment-là et les choses étaient claires
je les ai dites que matigon parle de de
malentendu vous parlez d'entourloupe il
pe pas y avoir de mal entendu attendez
écoutez il y a un texte première indice
première preuve il y a une réunion où je
parle en disant d'ailleurs attention il
y a le dallo aussi personne n'en parle
le droit opposable au logement et il y a
l'appel je le dis simplement parce
qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup de nos
compatriotes ont beaucoup de mal à se
loger on a du mal à se loger il y a un
mal logement en France et ensuite toute
la journée d'hier je la passe à échanger
avec le directeur de cabinet avec
Monsieur raster sur des rédaction et
donc depuis le matin la question était
la question de l'inclusion de cette ces
APL donc on peut pas Fermine de
découvrir à 17h le soir que il y a un
malentendu vous s tri par le
gouvernement mais mais quand on commence
une commission mixte paritaire il y a
forcément un certain nombre
d'engagements qui sont pris de part et
d'autres à partir du moment où j'ai
constaté que des engagements n'étaient
pas
tenus la confiance s érodé majorité m ch
vot côté c'est sans doute mon côté rural
et mon côté vend mais peu m'importe qu
ce qu'elle dit moi j'apporte des preuves
un texte les discussions à Matignon et
enfin pendant toute une journée et j'ai
à votre disposition i les différentes
versions des textes justement sur
l'article 1N qui soulève cette question
donc qu'on ne vienne pas me dire qu'il y
a un malentendu que tout à tout à coup
on découvre le poteau rose à 17h on vous
sent très énervé ce matin Bruno retillo
je suis pas énervé simplement je pense
que la question elle est cruciale et on
le voit bien 80 % des Français veulent
moins d'immigration et je le dis à mes
collègues de gauche aussi pour la
première fois c'est des Français de
droite des français de gauche voilà donc
ce mandat c'est pas Sénat seulement qui
nous l'a donné le texte vous vous
souvenez voter au 2 tiers bien plus
large que mon seul groupe LR mais
maintenant ce sont les Français qui nous
donnent ce mandat ce mandat de grande
fermeté par tout ça mais juste pour
revenir à la première question parce que
Gérald haranin il y a quelques minutes
dit qu'il croyait à un accord que vous
étiez d'accord sur quasiment tout est-ce
que vous dites ce matin qu'un accord est
possible ou pas Géral vermanin il joue
qui continue à lancer s quiill en l'air
ça c'est pas mon problème voilà il y a
des engagements j'entends à ce qu'il soi
respectés ces engagements et c'est le
texte du Sénat c'est de dire que il y a
un délai de carence c'est-à-dire que on
peut pas venir en France uniquement pour
toucher un certain nombre de dtes social
ça fait partie des pompes aspirantes
tout le monde est capable de le
comprendre bon c'est la question de la
me j'espère qu'on en parlera on va
parler après c'est le même système mais
donc ce ce délai de 40 il vaut pour les
allocations familiales il doit valoir
pour le droit opposable au logement il
doit valoir aussi pour les APL je
demande je demande à la chef de
gouvernement respecter ses engagements
je demande un délai de carence sur les
APL est-ce que vous pouvez aboutir à un
accord écoutez je je ne sais pas je vois
bien que il y a la question de leur
majorité le problème c'est un dilemme où
on respecte et on sert le texte du Sénat
c'est-à-dire et on l'a dit Gérard arch
l'a dit et compris d'ailleurs mes
collègues Hotti et Olivier marlex texte
du Sénat et désormais parî toutes les
vertus très bien c'est le texte du Sénat
le problème c'est que si c'est le texte
du Sénat ici ça passe bien au Sénat sauf
que ce qui semble se dessiner c'est que
à l'Assemblée ça pourrait moins bien se
passer mais si c'est l'affadissement du
texte du Sénat alors ça passera moins
bien au Sénat pour mieux passer à
l'Assemblée c'est pour ça que il faut
trouver un chemin ce chemin au moment où
je vous parle moi je dis qu'il n'est pas
trouvé et est-ce qu'il pourrait être
trouvé dans la journée ah ben je je peux
pas vous dire simplement là encore on
recommence une commission mix paritaire
à 10h30 10h30 c'est le début de la
réunion des groupes moi ce matin
j'iraiis chercher un mandat auprès de
mon groupe je n'irai pas à la CMP
j'estime que ma place c'est devant mon
groupe pour le présider pour expliquer
les choses et pour recevoir de la part
des sénateurs LR un mandat clair ça
n'est pas seulement brune rotillot voilà
qui négocie tel ou tel point je veux moi
puisque ça vous a pas échappé on a une
dimension d'équipe une dimension
collective qui est très forte voilà
cette dimension je la respecte donc je
ne ferai rien qui soit euh en
contradiction avec ce que veut mon
groupe je serai devant mon groupe et je
ne serai pas la commission X mais du
coup est-ce qu'il faut la décaler est-ce
que 10h30 c'est pas la bonne heure en
tout en tout cas il est hors de question
de voir cet article qui est l'article 1N
qui est le premier article qui doit
tomber dans l'ordre du jour de la
commission mi mais vous êtes président
du groupe est-ce que cette CMP peut
reprendre sans vous ah non mais la CMP
elle peut elle peut faire beaucoup de
choses simplement euh ce que je Mo ce
que je demande puisque ce sont les
réunions de groupe c'est important dans
la vie d'un d'un parlement les réunions
de groupe c'est ce qui donne le là c'est
ce qui donne la ligne donc moi je veux
être relégitimé dans ce mandat de
négociation par mon groupe et donc si la
commission mixte paritaire redémarre à
10h30 elle le peut mais elle ne doit en
aucun cas aborder un un point qui est
encore une fois
litigieux dans le même état d'esprit va
faire la même chose de son côté auprès
des députés LR Olivier marlex est pas
dans la même situation puisquil n'est
pas dans la commission paritaire j'y
suis et si j'ai tenu à y être c'est bien
parce que j'avais quelques méfiances
mais ça veut dire que vous allez
forcément la CMP n'aboutira pas si elle
aboutit avant que vous soyez revenu
puisque on imagine que les deux autres
sénateurs ne voteront pas si vous êtes
absent il y a un vote qui était prévu au
Sénat à 14h30 en cas de CMP conclusive
est-ce qu'il pourra se tenir à ch mais
bien sûr que non mais bien sûr que non
il faut parce que je je me demande si
les tpectateurs ils comprennent quelque
chose bon il y a si il y a il peut
encore y avoir un accord il peut ne pas
y avoir d'accord s'il y a pas d'accord
c'est pas non plus un drame le
gouvernement à ce moment là donne le
dernier mot s'il le souhaite à
l'Assemblée nationale et il y a un vote
à l'Assemblée nationale l'Assemblée
nationale s'il y a pas d'accord on on
jette le texte mais ça c'est son
problème c'est plus le M mais vous vous
le souhaitez pas je souhaite Tex soit
jeté non mais s y a pas d'accord que le
Tex tout travail moi j'ai siégé jour et
nuit hein et j'ai pas j'ai pas loupé une
heure de ce texte bon donc et et ensuite
j'ai assisté à toutes les réunions à
Matignon pour tenter de dégager euh un
accord pour l'intérêt général pour avoir
un texte qui soit le plus fort possible
mais faut pas que ce soit un texte
molasson ma ma crainte derrière bien sûr
euh c'est euh l'écriture du texte et
même s'il y avait un texte faut-il qu'il
ait la volonté d'appliquer fermement les
textes fermement voilà j'ai j'ai ici je
l'ai amené j'avais demandé aux
collaborateurs voyez de me dresser la
liste de tous les crimes viol qui ont
été commis par des gens qui étaient
illégalement sur le territoire français
les utef c'est incroyable c'est c'est
incroyable recto on va le regarder là à
l'heure actuelle vous dites c'est un
texte molçon non je ne veux pas qu'il
soit molaçon il y a des points qu'on a
acquis hier par exemple sur les quotas
sur le resserrement des conditions
familiales
sur voilà le D de séjour et
irrégulier mais on est voyez on a fait
une quinzaine d'articles il y en a
pratiquement une centaine un peu moins
donc il y a encore du chemin il est ça
peut durer jusqu'à quand géraldin il la
un pote en fin de soirée dura ça durera
le temps que ça durera je devais
m'envoler ce soir avec Géral archer en
Israël et bien s'il le faut je n'irai
pas en Israël et je resterai à bord du
navire voilà donc ça peut durer toute la
journée toute la nuit ça peut durer ce
que ça durera
Stéphane ça peut durer est que ça durera
il y a un moment où ça finira bien par
s'arrêter et il y il y a d'autres il y a
d'autres
négociations ou tractations qui sont
tenu en coulisse par exemple ellisabeth
Bor a a reçu des parlementaires
Renaissance hier à Matignon est-ce que
ça ça ça a du sens est-ce que ça
correspond bien àx procédure habituelle
d'une d' d'une CMP est-ce que ça ça vous
choque par exemple non dans une
commission mixte paritaire évidemment
que le gouvernement n'y est pas mais on
sait très bien que les présidents de
commission les rapporteur entretiennent
un dialogue notamment sur un texte don
l'initiative au départ c'est le
gouvernement un PJL et non pas une PP
une proposition non un projet de loi
donc ça c'est ça n'est pas choquant je
le vois sur chaque texte comme président
de groupe là évidemment ce texte là
concentre un certain nombre de
contradictions notamment de la macronie
pourquoi parce que ce texte il a
recherché entre nous un équilibre le
problème c'est pas l'équilibre le
problème c'est de faire baisser baisser
drastiquement l'immigration qui est a
échappé au contrôle du gouvernement donc
il faut rechercher un texte utile pas un
texte mêlant les gentils les méchants
non il faut un texte qui ne trompe pas
les Français qui ne soit pas un texte de
faux semblant et dans dans le même ordre
d'idée il a été dit hier soir que vous
que Emmanuel Macron vous avez appelé en
personne c'est c'est le cas ou pas du
tout foutise bon il vous a pas
appémanuel Macron j'ai jamais Emmanuel
Macron jeai jamais Emmanuel Macron il
m'a jamais appelé j'ai eu la premierère
ministre je l'ai même vu bien sûr mais
mais certainement pas avecuel Macron sûr
que non il vous a pas fait un message
passer un message comme quoi il fallait
trouver un accord non il l' pas vu non
il a pas fait de message est-ce que vous
avez rajouté vous des points hier en
dernière minute pour faire un peu monter
les enchères écoutez j'ai j'ai répondu à
cette question non non il y a le texte
du Sénat donc le texte du Sénat il est
sur la table depuis le départ il était
voté chacun le connaît ensuite il y a eu
trois réunions à Matignon est-ce que ma
voix a changé non depuis les engagements
que nous avons demander ça a toujours
été les mêmes voilà et encore une fois
toute la journée d'hier je n'ai rien
changé à ce que nous demandions depuis
le départ à ce qui était voté d'ailleurs
c'est un texte qui était voté encore une
fois ellisabeth borne hier elle s'est
engagée par écrit à faire une réforme de
l'aide médicale d'État au début de
l'année Gérald daranin lui s'est engagé
à réduire les délais de réalisation pour
les places en CRRA est-ce que c'est
suffisant pour vous ou est-ce que vous
en demandez plus non sur la me vous
voyez qu' on est capable de bouger
pourquoi est-ce que sur la me on s'est
rallié on a fait cette proposition tout
simplement parce que on savait que le
Conseil constitutionnel à tout coup
allait censurer donc on perdait tout on
perdait la me or la me là encore et le
fameux rapport Evin stéphanini le dit
nous sommes de toute l'Europe le pays le
plus favorable première chose et
deuxième chose l'aide médicale d'État
comme elle fonctionne aujourd'hui est
une aide au maintien de la clandestinité
là où il se trompe sans doute que ils
ont voulé faire plaisir à ceux qui
commandaient le rapport quand ils disent
que c'est tout est sous contrôle bien
sûr que non on a pris 100000
bénéficiaires en plus en quelques années
100000 là j'ai leur tableau et on voit
par exemple je vais le dire aux
auditeurs que la dialyse on est en 1 an
à plus 17 % que sur la chimiothérapie on
est en 1 an à 20 % que sur la
radiothérapie on est à 34 % 34 % le
système ème de soins français est au
bord de l'effondrement alors il faut
faire venir encore plus de clandestin je
parle pas d' rapport de Ligas je je je
non non non
nonpp aussi que aussi rapport de li mais
bien sûr donc nous voulons la réforme de
la me c'est impératif il faut contrôler
parce que là aussi je pense que ça fait
partie des pompes aspirantes quoi qu'on
en dise bien et donc gerérard arché a
reçu hier une lettre de madame la
Première ministre qui s'engage dans les
T premiers mois de l'année prochaine à
inscrire un PGL à l'ordre du jour sur
ouais juste sur quelle réforme parce
qu'on entendait Géral ranin dimanche il
disait moi je pense pas que le problème
ce soit le panier de soins le problème
c'est le statut de ceux qui sont à c'est
le problème du panier de soins écoutez
les paniier de soins pour des
clandestins c'est le même que pour des
Français qui payent sauf deux choses les
cures bon on imagine mal qu'on paye une
cure thermale quand même ou la PMA
pareil on l'imagine pas voilà donc c'est
unpr de panier pourquoi est-ce que tous
les pays est-ce que vous pensez que
l'Allemagne la Suède et les autres pays
europeope sont plus inhumains qu'en
France ils ont pas plus de problème de
santé publique donc là encore on est en
train d'éclater tous les records on va
arriver en fin d'année à 466000
bénéficiaires en fin d'année et on voit
bien que le déficit même si ce n'est pas
la sécurité sociale qu'il prend en
charge l'an prochain c'est 11 milliards
le trou de la SCU en 2027 17 milliards
on continue comme ça on continue avec
nos pompes aspirantes dans tous les sens
ou est-ce qu'on prend en main le
contrôle de tous les instruments on est
humain bien sûr qu'on doit soigner ceux
qui sont malades d'une femme qui est
enceinte c'est ce que nous avons proposé
mais on arrête on arrête le
laxisme le rassemblement national vous
les avez s entendu depuis hier soir dit
que ce qui se passe c'est une victoire
idéologique pour eux est-ce que vous
avez le sentiment de faire le jeu du RN
mais le rassemblement national eux
essaie de courir après nous ça fait des
années vous êtes bien placé je suis à
Public Sénat vous savez parfaitement que
la réforme de laame on l'a même fait
voter dans le cadre des projets de loi
de finance il y a plusieurs années les
rapports de François Noel buffet ça fait
des années on n pas changé de pied voilà
simplement ceux qui font le jeu sur les
prestations sociales ceux qui font le
jeu du rassemblement national c'est ceux
qui pratiquent la politique de
l'autruche vous savez pourquoi les
Pays-Bas il y a quelques semaines ont vu
la victoire de au législatif de
l'extrême droite parce que les Pays-Bas
ont accueilli 400000 immigrés l'an
dernier rapporter à la population
française c'est comme si la France avait
accueilli 16 immigrés ça ne tient pas et
à chaque fois il y a un lien entre un
comment dirais-je une relation directe
entre le résultat des démagogues et la
non prise en compte de ce que demande le
peuple la maîtrise de l' migration quand
un gouvernement ne durcit pas ces
instruments de législature enfin pardon
de de juridique et bien à tous les coups
dans les urnes les peuples se révoltent
bien moi je ne veux pas en arriver là
est-ce que vous êtes d'accord sur la
stratégie sur ce qui s'est passé hier
avec vos alliés centristes est-ce que
vous avez parlé avec HERV Marseille
alors vraiment je je veux le dire ici
que c'est vraiment pas ni Hervé
Marseille ni Philippe bon carer qui nous
ont posé des problèmes je je veux
vraiment les remercier parce que on a
des différences entre nous on est à
droite ils sont au centre on on a fait
un texte ensemble qui est un texte quand
même très très ferme et j'imagine que
pour eux aussi ça pas toujours été
simple Hervé on a toujours été dans un
dialogue hier encore hier soir tard non
croyez-moi que ce sont des partenaires
alliés qui ont été parfaitement
F juste il disait hier soir Hervé
Marseille c'est pas l'affaire des appels
qui va faire capoter l'accord si on
n'est pas foutu de trouver une solution
c'est qu'il y a un problème
institutionnel vous êtes d'accord avec
ça oui euh je veux rajouter un point
peut-être que c'est une révélation
d'ailleurs euh lorsqu'il s'est agit
lorsque il y a un peu plus de 8 jours il
y a eu cet échec à l'Assemblée nationale
avec le le vote de la mention de Roger
les deux présidents des deux assemblées
y bronf pour l'Assemblée nationale et
Gérard arché ont conseillé au chef de
l'État de faire passer un peu de temps
de tenir une CMP si la CMP devait être
tenue non pas dans la précipitation mais
plutôt au mois de janvier pour donner du
temps au temps pour qu'on arrive à
travailler convenablement pour que on
puisse par petit pas essayer de dégager
un accord le chef de l'État en a décidé
autrement il a précipité les choses le
problème d'aujourd'hui et c'est sans
doute ce que voulait dire aussi Hervé
Marseille parce qu'on en a parlé hier
avec Géral archet dans son bureau c'est
que cette précipitation en réalité est
un frein pour trouver des accords quand
vous précipitez les choses je vois bien
le Paris qui a derrière en précipitant
il s'est dit bon ma majorité de devra
accepter et et mes oppositions aussi le
fait accompli c'est ça le part initial
donc c'est la la volonté de
précipitation d'Emmanuel Macron qui
conduit ce matin au blocage et peut-être
ce soir l'échec je je je suis pas aussi
affirmatif que ça je dis que dans le
contexte que nous vivons aujourd'hui
cette précipitation n'a pas été une aide
pour dégager une voie de passage c'est
tout est-ce est-ce que je peux poser la
question autrement s'il y a s'il y a
vousz pas besoin de me demander
autorisation pour me poser des questions
si si s'il y a une volonté d'aller aussi
vite et cetera et si d'où vient le
blocage est-ce que c'est pas aussi parce
que le le le le gouvernement ou
l'exécutif redoute la réaction de sa
propre majorité si bien sûr si si c'est
c'est de là que vient le blocage
finalement c'est-à-dire que la peur de
pas réunir le le quorum nécessaire à
l'Assemblée pour voter le texte infé je
je pense que le quorum je pense qu'en
tout cas pour ce qui concerne en
discutant avec marlex et
avecti je vois bien que une très très
grande majorité de notre groupe et l'air
sera prêt à à voter un
T ouis bien sûr bien s il y aura
peut-être deux tro ou quatre défections
rien du tout rien du tout c'est quand
Mme rien à voir avec la vingtaine qui a
eu pendant la réforme des retrait le
problème c'est pas l'air mais vous savez
depuis problème c'est qui alors c'est
Renaissance et le modème depuis le début
depuis le début moi ce que j'ai vu c'est
que ce texte tente c'est le texte de
l'EN même temps on tente de faire plus
de régularisation avec plus d'expulsion
mais ça ça marche pas nous la régular
fin en même temps on est arriv c'est la
fin du en même temps bien sûr voilà le
en même temps ça précip la France dans
l'immobilisme ça prépite les Français
dans la désespérance au sens d'être
privé d'une espérance privé d'espoir au
sens de l'anxiété vous savez dans un
monde qui va si mal où tout bouge quand
vous avez un président de la République
où les repères changent tous les jours
sans ligne très très stable c'est une
présidence anxiogène évidemment mais si
on est arrivé au bout d'un système où on
est dans une espèce de crise
institutionnelle tel qu'évoqué par Hervé
Marseille hier ou ce que vous êtes en
train de nous dire ce matin est-ce que
ça ve dire ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire qu'il faut changer de premier
ministre il faut dissoudre l'Assemblée
c'est c'est quoi les les les pistes
derrière pour relancer la machine moi
moi ce que j'observe c'est que EML
Macron
euh pratique une forme d'antigolisme
euh c'est-à-dire que il ne va pas il a
des instruments que lui confère la
Constitution iluse il en abuse le 493 et
je pourrais parler d'ailleurs de ce qui
s'est passé aussi sur le projet de loi
de finance parce que y compris les
apports du Sénat ont été parfaitement
négligés donc c'est un 49 C brutal qui
n'entend transiger avec aucune des
assemblées or sén ça a joué ça quand
même le fait que vos apports n'ai pas
été repris dans le Budet c'est dans la
toile de fond s passé hier ce que je
veux dire je m'explique c'est que il use
il abuse des instruments les plus
coercitifs de ce qu'on appelle le
parlementarisme rationalisé et en même
temps il refuse le référendum il refuse
d'aller au peuple ou alors il inventent
des procédures les conventions citoyenne
un conseil national le fondation un
grand débat les rencontres de
Saint-Denis je ne sais quelle autre
initiative de grande ampleur au mois de
janvier c'est une forme d'antigolisme
c'est une forme de pratique de la
Constitution qui n'est pas fidèle avec
son esprit juste pour pour revenir du
coup à cette CMP bon vous nous dites
quand même que vous dites c'est une
toile de fond ça veut dire que ça a
quand même un peu joué que le fait que
vous vos arguments vous devriez vous
devriez devez poser cette question
invitez-le à gérarché et il vous dira
pour l'instant il se tait pour donner
toute sa chance à la Commission à la
commission mixte paritaire sur le texte
migration quand il sera libéré s'il est
de ce poid-là il pourra vous en discuter
très très librement et il vous dira le
fond de sa pensée sur ce qui s'est passé
sur le 493 et sur le PLF quelle est la
vôre du coup pardon quelle est la vôtre
parce que j'imagine que vous avez à peu
près la même elle est la même que la
sienne oui d'ord donc on s je viens
d'exprimer juste sur pour revenir juste
à ce qui va se passer ce matin don on a
bien compris qu'il y avait un B clash
sur la question des aPL est-ce que sur
le reste il y a d'autres points
bloquants ou pas il y a beaucoup de
points qui sont bloquants la logique du
Sénat encore encore une fois c'est moins
d'entrée plus de sorties moins
d'expulsion notre article 4 bis pas de
droitosable pas de fraude à la comment
dirais-je de de de frauder donc de prime
à la fraude sur les clandestins ça c'est
pour les régularisations on a verrouillé
vraiment l'article 4 bis là encore il
faut plusexpulsion plus d'interdiction
du territoire français c'est l'article 9
l'article 10 on sera un c'est bon sur la
régularisation dans on bougera pas on l'
on va le durcir notamment pour faire
rentrer casier judiciaire sur les
condamnations mais l'article 10 n'est
pas négociable pas de droit opposable
pour un clandestin la encore une fois la
frute ne doit pas payer et là-dessus
l'accord n'est pas trouvé des expulsions
j'espère que si mais aujourd'hui comme
les accords sont remis en cause je je ne
peux pas y mettre ma main au feu ensuite
les expulsions je viens d'en parler et
enfin les pompes aspirantes c'est le
modèle social français trop généreux on
veut réduire l'attractivité sur la me
les étrangers malades ou encore sur les
prestations sociales c'est aussi le code
de la nationalité la
déchéance de la nationalité pour les
binationaux quand ils ont assassiné un
policier ou un gendarme c'est normal
c'est la résurgence du délit bien sûr
pour le séjour illégal c'est aussi un
certain nombre d'autres dispositions sur
lesquelles on tiendra le cap des
dispositions qui nécessiteront de
modifier la Constitution vous êtes
toujours dans l'idée de demander une
réforme constitutionnelle sur ces
pointslà je pense que sans la réforme
constitutionnelle sans la possibilité de
faire un référendum sans la
possibilité de réinstaller au cœur du
débat politique ce qu'on appelle la
souveraineté populaire c'est-à-dire la
décision du peuple français je pense que
bien sûr tout ce que l'on pourra voter
sera soumis aux décisions des cours
suprêmes qui ont un logiciel qui n'est
pas le nôtre elle considère qu'il vaut
mieux protéger au nom de la protection
des droits individuels qu' vaut mieux
protéger des individus dangereux que de
protéger la société française c'est
terrible quand vous avez l'interdiction
la commission des lois a révélé par
exemple
un individu qui avait eu 42
condamnations qu'on ne pouvait pas
expulser bon mais quand la cdH condamne
la France qu'Open des droits de l'homme
parce que on on renvoie un oubec ou
alors récemment des Russes et et autres
parce que ils sont radicalisés ils sont
menaçants pour la France mais que il ne
pourrai pas avoir de procès équitable
dans leur pays dont certains d'ailleurs
passent leurs vacances dans ces pays-là
on tombe à la renverse mais là Gérald
armanin reste ferme sur le casion fera
tout pour pas le faire revenir vous Salz
ça fa c'est ce qu'il dit non mais c'est
ce qu'il dit dans l'instant mais je
pense qu'il faudra des réformes qui
soient structurelles il faut préserver
l'état de droit ce que je veux dire
c'est que à la source de l'État de droit
il y a la démocratie la souveraineté
populaire certes une majorité ne peut
pas écraser le droit mais le droit ne
peut pas non plus écraser la position
d'une majorité c'est pour ça qu'il
faudra un référendum en tout cas le
recours facilité au référendum c'est pas
par les conventions citoyennes c'est pas
par par les bidules et les machins que
nous invente le président de la
République tous les de mois que on
parviendra à renouer une confiance et à
restaurer en réalité la démocratie de
notre pays et vous l'avez redemandé à
Emmanuel Macron cette réforme
constitutionnelle vous lui avez écrit
une lettre mais comment vous comptez la
faire passer vous avez déjà essayé à
l'Assemblée national le texte a dû être
retiré avant la fin de l'examen et au
Sénat vous avez dû même le retirer avant
le début sûûr bien sûr bien sûr non non
mais ça ça dépend du chef de l'État il
ne le souhaite pas il ne le souhaite pas
séanel que je disais que sa pratique de
la 5e République n'était pas du tout
gaulienne niigoliste vos alliés centr
tristes non plus ne le souit pas vous
avez ét mis enorité au Sénou parti ça
fait partie des points de divergence euh
mais vous savez je ne suis pas un
illibéral juste un un mot quand Édouard
baladure s'aperçoit que le Conseil
constitutionnel en 93 présidé par
Monsieur B d'Inter veut appliquer de
façon très laxiste une directive
européenne il dit non ce que vous dites
là le Conseil constitutionnel c'est pas
ce que dit le constitoiant et il va
faire une révision de la Constitution
euh qui va contredire la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel monsieur
baladure était-il un dangereux illibéral
non je pense qu'aujourd'hui la dérive
que je vous ai comment dira décrite avec
cette exaltation des droits individuels
au mépris du cadre collectif l'intérêt
particulier plutôt que l'intérêt général
est en train de corroder notre nos
équilibres démocratiques les Français
veulent un texte veulent un texte avec
plus de fermeté est-ce qu'en cas d'échec
dans la journée ce soir demain vous
craignez de le payer vous
de le payer politiquement non mais les
Français veulent un texte mais ils
veulent un texte de fermeté les Français
ne veulent pas un texte molasson voilà
les Français veulent que on puisse
reprendre des instruments j beaucoup de
mesures de fermeté qui ont été acceptées
est-ce que vous n'avez pas peur d'aller
trop loin de faire faire céder la corde
c'est c'est une cohérence et encore une
fois tout se tient les questions je le
disais tout à l'heure en matière par
exemple le retour du dispositif pasqui
un étranger qui nît de parents étrangers
en France ne doit pas devenir dire par
hasard français il doit y avoir un
consentement une manifestation de sa
propre volonté et cetera c'est pas des
choses qui sont des choses et
poustoufflante d'autres pays le font moi
mon souci voyez c'est que la France de
tous les pays européens sur beaucoup de
points elle est la mieux disante je
voudrais au moins que la France demain
soit pas la mieux disisante mais
revienne dans la moyenne européenne et
ne se fasse pas connaître des filières
de l'immigration comme le bon élève le
pays où on est le bienvenu où il y a le
carnet de chèque et les français sont là
que pour payer des cotisations des
impôts de plus en plus voilà il y a pas
de volonté d'aler d'humilier le
gouvernement parce qu'on on a le
sentiment que du coup le texte est à
votre main non non écoutez je je parle
d'engagement c'est c'est mal me
connaître que de penser que je souhaite
humilier quiconque je je veux simplement
que les engagements soient respés je
veux simplement qu'on aboutisse ensemble
à un texte qui soit un bon texte je le
redis aujourd'hui et ce texte là il a
été voté par les macronistes il a été
voté par les horizons au Sénat bien
au-delà de
notre majorité à nous et de mon groupe à
moi donc qu' viennent pas me dire qu'il
est invotable conv viennent pas me dire
que c'est un texte pour les fous furieux
il a réuni vous rendez compte très peu
de textes réunissent une telle majorité
les 2 tiers de l'Assemblée sénatoriale
les 2 tiers merci Bro on suivra
évidemment ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
autour de cette commission mix paritaire
Stéphane laun de wouest France tout
autre sujet les États du Pacifique Sud
entre fragilité et rivalité à la de
votre journal merci beaucoup on passe au
club des territoires on continue de
parler de cette to immigration